ich will hier
[Musik]
es gäbe also ein geheimnisvoller ort mit
vielen ungelösten rätsel aus dem man
unbedingt raus will kann man sagen dass
thüringen auch sogar das absolut absolut
schon seit meinem amtsantritt gut da
habe ich sage es immer das kapital würde
über den rennsteig fürchten und die
bananen würden knapp so halten der es
ging ja man und es sind nicht im
kanzleramt nicht den kannst du jetzt mal
ganz weg von der politik
ok es wird noch grausamer ich schmeiße
mich vollends blutige leben so kurz dass
sein
es sollen rief er zu kommen ich habe in
einem nervengift präpariert das stück
aber glaubt mir ist es zu verletzt wenn
ihr euch als würdig erweist über das
natürlich das gegenbild schafft ihr es
nicht sollten die gewalt jetzt scheiße
gelaufen
wir sind im prinzip tote da stunde wenn
wir das jetzt nicht schaffen
das setzt voraus dass das nervengift auf
nerven wird
ja aber ich hab' nerven wie drahtseile
sehr gute einstellung
früher war ja die linke die
protestpartei
heute ist es die afd was macht die afg
besser sagen wir mal die ausgrenzung
strategie die früher dazu geführt haben
dass sich der protest an uns gebunden
hat ist weitergezogen und alle reden
über die afg und in jeder talkshow dass
sie dabei sein und das ergebnis ist dass
man in den neuen ländern offenkundig ein
teil der wählerinnen und wähler abholen
kann die sagt wenn wir wollen dass in
berlin laut gequetscht wird
da muss man das kreuzchen bei der afg
machen
wir müssen jetzt mal loslegen wir sind
in einer stunde tot außer wir finden das
gegengift sie sehen da ist eine kerze
die stimmen aus
woanders eine kerze steht da zwei
abnutzungsspuren sind da was bedeutet
das sehr gut
wir brauchen noch eine dritte kerze da
ist die dritte kerze sie ist allerdings
verschlossen kalt es wird aber langsam
wärmer wärmer das sind kalt nein sie
liefert nichts damit zu tun
ja ja keine heißt mai nicht heißt dass
kein eis heißt heißt jetzt schnell nach
jetzt wird's nochmal hier richtig
spannend jetzt schnell die karte raus
die zeit läuft haben wir müssen den raum
so langsam verlassen sonst wird's hier
brenzlig da ist eine tür auf einer muss
als erster durch den tunnel ich nicht
das setzt sich das gibt es so was
glauben sie wird enger dieser tunnel
oder ihre wiederwahl im oktober sind
sind sie optimistischer wir hatten
schröder wollte rein sie wollen raus da
weiß man interessant wir dürfen jetzt
sie dürfen jetzt nicht in panik
verfallen
ich sehe was was sie nicht sehen ich
weiß nicht wie ich darauf komme weil wir
gerade in einem schlachthaus sind aber
machen sich sorgen um ihren
koalitionspartner die spd wenn man das
rotlicht zumindest eine option dass man
aufpassen muss
wir brauchen eine regeneration damit die
roten blutkörperchen
auch bei der spd sich wiederholen es
muss wieder deutlich röter er das bild
ja dass wir uns mal konzentrieren jahre
nicht als abschaum lage ist ja wie
kommen wir was wird jetzt noch mal
nachdenken eine taschenlampe die könnt
uns helfen
sehr gut der wesen sehr gut sehr gut
sehr gut sehr gut
jetzt schließen wir hier auch ich bin
auch so zu nennen
die linke hält die nato ja für überholt
wie fühlt sich das an in der
weltanschauung schnittmengen mit donald
trump zu haben herr trump hat den edf
vertrag das ist der atom
abrüstungsvertrag einfach gekündigt mit
unserem land ist darüber kann wort
geredet worden
und ich finde wer einfach solche
abrüstungsverträge um die wir in den
80er und 90er jahren als also ich
jedenfalls als junger mensch gekämpft
haben wenn man das einfach streicht und
das wort ab richtung gar nicht mehr
vorkommt dann geht dieser welt in die
falsche richtung
gut das nervengas willkommen sind sagen
würde wäre ich meine gesamte ja dazu
gefasst kann auch sein dass es daran
die nerven also wir müssen jetzt hier
irgendwo ein bzw
sie suchen jetzt hier mal ein code damit
wie diesen code gleich ins keypad
eingeben können indem sie über den tag
schon sagen das war ja mein sich mit
coach ich meine das englische code nicht
als deutsche kult wie sie beschissen
nein alles gute nicht beschützen als sie
sehen fantastisch aus wie sie das hier
machen mit welcher eleganz
[Musik]
eine blutige hand und unter dieser
blutigen hand drücken wir den code da ja
ok unter die tür aber es sieht auch
nicht ab er hat doch aber ab jetzt also
niemals so abgefressen herr ramelow
jetzt wird es richtig spannend wir
müssen jetzt teamwork machen kennen sie
kino wollte der politik ja absolut
das heißt rot rot grün das ist ihm
wurscht
rot-rot-grün ja das steht da nicht aber
sogar stetig schnell so jetzt aber in
zentrieren und jetzt nochmal richtig
spannend sie müssen jetzt da oben
eintippen ich rufe ihn zu und sie nehme
macht es genau umgekehrt nicht rüber
durch den tunnel sie bleiben hier ja wie
sie nehmen den handel nach oben ich
dirigiere ihre handeln zu können und sie
geben den code ein
ich sehe jetzt ihre hand hier hören sie
mich herr ramelow ich sehe ihre hand so
gehen sie jetzt mal mit der hand ein
bisschen runter ja jetzt drücken sie mit
ihrem zeigefinger sehr gut dann weiter
runter
noch einmal drücken und jetzt nach
rechts sehr gut das war der code und
jetzt ist hier was passiert hier ist ein
buch umgefallen
sie müssen sogar zurückkommen
lesen sie gerne bücher was für bücher
lesen sie mal war mäßig gegen israel als
in diesem roman henning mankell erklärt
ihr hang zu fiction und fantasy auch
ihre liebe zu karl marx also fiction und
fantasy der ist schon ein
wissenschaftler gut das kapital kennt
man natürlich finden sich alarmiert dass
das die jugend beim kapital nicht mehr
in mag's denkt sondern anbrach
aber ich denke dann als kapital und sie
meine frage verstand nee jetzt das sind
politiker die das ist geschickt die
umgehen das immer so naja aber ich eher
ein älterer mensch und bei mir später
karl may noch eine größere rolle ob man
stellt die frage noch mal finden sie ist
alarmierend dass die jugend heute beim
kapital nicht mehr am markt denkt
sondern anbrach
also ich kenn brahms capital brach der
rapper der deutsche rapper capital hat
mehr nummer eins ist als die beatles
jetzt schon das kann sein aber ich bin
ein älterer mensch und ich finde die
beatles wagen für mich schon meine
jugend um meine kindheit er
lassen sie mich jetzt nicht verwirren
durch erwarten die bücher sind hier um
gefallen jetzt müssen wir uns eines
dieser bücher anschauen ich gebe einen
hinweis in einem dieser bücher ist etwas
verstellt und da finden wir einen
schlüssel denn ich erinnere noch mal
dran
wir sterben gleich wir müssen das
gegengift finden wo finden wir das ding
ist bevor wir das ausschießen setzen uns
noch mal hin
ich will noch kurz mit ihm plaudern sind
sie musikalisch also kann kein
instrument spielen also behaupte ich
jetzt mal wer damit nicht falsche
eindruck erwecke meine mein vater war
hochmusikalisch und meine geschwister
spielen alle instrumente ich beneide die
aber tatsächlich als kind bin ich schwer
geplagt gewesen mit legasthenie dass die
geschichte war sozusagen die buchstaben
durch den kopf so lang her
damit verbindet sich eine
links rechts koordinations problematik
also die bildet sich auch noch mal im
gehirn ab ganz klassisch wenn man auf
dem linken bein steht greift man mit
rechts oder beim linkshänder genau
umgekehrt also das heißt sie sind
vielleicht gar kein linker sondern
richte ich bin also alles im kopf als
allseits einsatzfähig das vermute ich
meine partei ja ja interessant was hier
so drei tage seit werden kann gut ding
sagt mir jedenfalls die kirchgemeinde
wenn ich dabei bin und hören sie mal ich
würde mir gerne ich hätte so gerne die
welt gesehen und zum bahnhof gehen wo
die züge stehen wo der lokomotive dampf
ablässt und erschaffen als die fahrkarte
loch puff puff puff die ist wunderbar
über berg und tal überhöhen und werd
jetzt noch mal gesagt dass sie gut
singen angeht da geht es um
kirchendiener und haben sie geprobt
gesungen
schließen sie jetzt das klavier ja aber
mit ein bisschen glück finden wir
vielleicht das gift so und jetzt das ist
also es passt zu ihrem gesang lange
nahost der van dorst wieso naja das ist
für beide trinken haben jetzt das ist
für eine haltung ja also ich denke dass
jetzt ich will hier ist es gegen gibt ja
viel haben sie mir auch nicht übrig
gelassen
ich wollte sichergehen dass überleben
aber ist das nicht auch deprimierend
jetzt und sie haben es geschafft sich zu
befreien doch wieder zurück nach
thüringen
dass ich überhaupt nicht deprimieren ich
finde thüringen großartig genießen sie
es noch auf der gewinnerseite zu sein
speichern sie das gefühl ab wer weiß
wann es wieder kommt ich bedanke mich
vielen dank herr am 9
[Musik]
wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat dann
drückt auch auf gefällt mir abonniert
diesen kanal damit ihr keine sklaven
verpasst ja und wir gehen jetzt auch
nach hause und vision hier noch mal
feucht durch ich würde den schwamm und
sie denn einmal okay herr ramelow